(marching music)
- Molossia is an expression
of personal sovereignty
out of creativity, imagination,
and maybe a little bit
of dash of satire.
We would like to poke a little bit of fun,
and it's kind of easy to do
that when you're a tiny country
inside a gigantic country.
I am President Kevin Baugh,
the president of the Republic of Molossia.
This is my nation.
Welcome to the Republic of Molossia.
Right over there is the United States.
And right over here is our country.
My nation is a micronation,
which means a tiny, self-declared nation
and usually located
within another country,
as is Molossia inside the United States.
The United States does
not recognize Molossia,
although we did get a
very nice Christmas card
from President Obama.
I would say that the U.S. considers us
sort of an extension of free speech.
For the record, we do pay taxes.
However, we call it foreign aid.
You've seen the roads.
The U.S. needs all the help they can get,
so we're there for 'em.
We like to do things that
are different and unique
and unusual in Molossia.
We are actually very proud
of our space program.
Ooh, yes!
Molossia does have a currency.
It's called the valora,
which means "valuable" in Esperanto,
which is our second language.
We also have our own measurement system.
Our total population right now is 32.
And we have our own timezone.
Many of our civil servants
in Molossia are mannequins,
because they don't complain
and they don't charge a whole lot.
They never go on strike,
that kind of thing.
There are hundreds of
micronations around the world
in just about every
country you can imagine.
The Conch Republic, which
is Key West, Florida.
Sealand, a very famous micronation
located off the coast of Britain.
It's really an amazingly
creative group of people
that decide they want to
have their own country.
I originally founded
the Republic of Molossia
back in 1977 when I was 15,
and I just stayed with
it through the years.
It is a lot of work running Molossia,
because I want Molossia to
be a functioning nation.
I want it to be as much
like a larger nation
as it possibly can be.
I love being the president of Molossia.
I really do.
It's second only to my family
as one of my great loves in life.